hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
right now i'm in huddersfield
it's a beautiful day and i'm standing
with my very good friend jl spoon how
are you doing jl hey guys i'm well thank
you now for anyone that doesn't know jay
i would like to introduce yourself
yes my name is gerald spooner and i am
samuel lee's first ever student
so she came to the property investors
crash course back in
2014 2014 and very recently about a few
months ago
she bought this incredible house and at
the time of buying the house
you talked about what you were going to
do with it you talked about how you're
gonna renovate
it refinance it turn it into a massive
hmo nine bedrooms
has it worked out okay it's been crazy
but yes it's working out perfectly the
last time i came there
there was there was a uh a sold board
outside
but now it's a room's tillette board
outside it might as well be taken down
because all the rooms have been left
so all the rumors have been left and
actually surprisingly not by the agent
by yourself
by myself so in this video we're going
to talk about interior design
configuring a property to add value how
to turn the house into a hmo
all kinds of stuff and how to get
tenants so jl show us around
[Music]
oh things have changed a little bit
we used a rich color yeah um i wanted a
mirror to expand it
and you know we just wanted to give it a
bit of laughs it's really really nice
this area wasn't too bad before but it
looks like you've put this green
paint on it what was the reason for the
degree um i just wanted to add some
color and some character
yeah i just thought it was really
vibrant it goes with the house as well
like a rich turquoise i like it oh this
is
oh wow yes we added
so last one we came this was the room
whereby there was a build on the floor
yes fixing the pipeline he was fixing
the pipe for the en-suite bathrooms
right there you've gone really high-end
i have
but on a low and reasonable budget to be
honest with you it looks
fabulous thank you so talk to me about
this room and
because a lot of people even myself
sometimes i'm doing a refurb i'm
thinking
colors yeah you don't i don't say you
want to be too out there
and i've heard a lot of people say
actually they say don't make it too
out there because you you're alienate
some people and they go with magnolia
everywhere
you obviously haven't gone no no i've
completely the opposite
i've just done key rooms that will
really pull people in and it really
worked because i rented out the entire
house within like
10 days so yeah how many rooms
seven rooms out seven rooms but i've
actually rented that one twice
right and what did you do you send them
away no no
um so john's upstairs at the moment he's
renting it until the other tenant comes
and moves in in july
oh so someone literally said someone
said i can move
what did the agent say to you what
happened so an agent actually said to me
um you know they came in they loved it
they said look to be honest
um you're not gonna get seven people in
the house at the same time
um you should consider having about five
people in the house at the same time
and you'll also uh won't be able to fill
up the house for two to three months
and you've got seven people within 10
days
respect one of them and and and this
this painting
yeah so i just it's beautiful i wanted a
lovely painting in the living room
everything i found was just so expensive
and i did this for little to no money
this was like a 30
40 pound canvas and then paint from
wherever i could find in the house
so you painted it i painted this that is
you're one of a kind it's my first ever
painting guys
a special a special kind of person well
i love the room i love the room and
where did you get where did you get
stuff like this one
amazon yeah just online amazon
you know you know i'm a fan of this yeah
what happened
around the rest of the house nice very
very nice vinyls
very heavy yeah totally compliant
so this is the kitchen okay
this looks good very bright so
um is this a new kitchen it's not i mean
the floor is new
but i actually just painted the unit and
took off
the the tiles resourceful
yeah it looks kind of like a new kitchen
you've done really well i've changed the
handles as well i've changed the handles
it it's deceiving it looks like you
change the
yeah we're gonna get home to the
basement because the plan
we're gonna we're gonna put an apartment
in the basement but we'll talk about
that later
when we spoke yeah about three months
ago we did a tour of this house
this was a bathroom and there was two
bathrooms and jl said there's no need
for two bathrooms i want to turn one
bathroom into a bedroom
let's see how it looks very nice yes
so this was a bathroom originally um and
we just
took everything out and put bears in it
and dancing you know what's crazy about
that
it's just so crazy that you got a whole
bedroom out of the bathroom
and the bathroom was pointless wasn't it
yeah because there was another bathroom
right there
absolutely so this bathroom with now a
bed in it we've
been ripped out which costs probably not
a lot how much
rent are you getting for this room this
room is 350.
350 a month in huddersfield folks
350 and 100 yeah i mean a lot of houses
don't rent out for much more than that
and you've literally just got one big
house
turned the bathroom into a little
bedroom 350 rent
genius genius love it in terms of
reconfiguration as well
there was a room upstairs humongous room
i know there's lots of rooms probably
can't get every single room
and the room was so big that i was doing
cartwheels in it yeah um
and you basically took this bathroom out
but put an ensuite upstairs
can we see that room yes of course
absolutely this room
was the seventh room and um
yeah it was just one big space it was
massive
john would you prefer this room if it
was much bigger but no ensuite or if it
had an old sweep it was this size
i'd say it would be fairly unsweet there
we go
kind of like dead space almost doesn't
it yeah it was it was that big
literally i was doing cartwheels in here
yeah it was massive it was all the way
down so yeah
well it's hard because i mean you're
sharing when you know somebody comes in
next door they'll be shaving them in the
bathroom so that'll change
cleaning i mean fortunately they're
friends
yeah which is great but yeah you know
it's better than going all the way
downstairs isn't it absolutely
this room so so so you rented this out
from about six weeks onwards
but in the meantime john's staying here
so i've got somebody
booked in a month or so from now yeah
and
i thought there was a big uh sort of
eight week gap
yeah uh and and john came through and
was just like looking for somewhere for
a month or two
and we just fit him in within that time
so you just put this wall in right so we
just put that
a bathroom yes which is shared right
it's a shared bathroom yeah right
yeah great good job so a bathroom shared
with two people yeah
and these rooms are renting out roughly
about four to five each yeah
great awesome doing a great job
obviously we went upstairs and um if
you'd remembered where the actual
bathroom has been installed there was a
cupboard there
and on the cupboard were two huge doors
like this
and i wanted to stay in budget so
instead of getting brand new doors
i actually got them to take it off put
this here and have a
slide very nice yeah very resourceful
yeah also it's actually quite i like the
idea of a sliding door because if you
haven't
it just takes up space doesn't it so
yeah that's pretty brilliant it
definitely makes a difference
it does and this is such a lovely spot
we went out for coffee just a few doors
down there's a nice little
um cafe there and yeah yeah it's perfect
right in the heart of um huddersfield
yeah
and i think that's why it rents out so
quickly
all right so come on in so this is the
green room
and funny enough um this room
was the one that was most sought after
like just got so many messages from
people saying i want the green room i
want the green room so my
story is if you want to get tenants
quick just use this exact paint
and hopefully or or or become a painter
yeah i know one of my one of my art
pieces yeah it was meant for the
corridor but
you know you thought it was the most
popular we haven't put it up yet so it's
awesome how do you find time to paint
when you're doing running around
being a landlady do you know what i
don't even know
how i found the time but i just did i
just was like do not forget everything
let me just paint for a day so how much
is this room renting out for
this room is rented out for i believe
it's
four seven five yeah um yeah
so basement downstairs that's been real
fun and games hasn't it it's been great
so to begin with we met up with the
builders
we put together some nice drawings of
how we were going to have it as
an apartment yes with two bedrooms and
that was a great plan it was great
what happened well yorkshire water
have still not gotten back to me about
doing the works in the basement
why is that important why do you need
yorkshire because in order to separate
it into a separate title
separate flat you need to separate all
the utilities which i've done gas
electricity
tax done address done yorkshire water
so you were waiting on yorkshire water
to
so that you could then get planning
permission to have a separate apartment
now meanwhile while that was happening
these rooms are so fast
and then you had an idea and you thought
actually hold on a minute
yeah we could just do downstairs as two
or even three bedrooms
which would mean that we'd get more
rents which would push the value up
of the house literally which would mean
that when you refinance pulling out
everything honest to god literally right
that's what i was thinking
and it's really important lesson here
because a lot of people have
spent so much time on the drawings and
you know meeting all the architects
would be would be absolutely set on i
want to finish what started but
sometimes you just got to be a bit fluid
well the thing is you romanticize
it it's all very much like oh yes i'm
going to make my own self-contained flat
but it's like love what's the numbers
yes numbers and you're constantly
teaching that
and i got a bit carried away emotionally
with the property but when i've realized
now the figures and the numbers it just
makes so much sense to be in a 9-10
bedroom hmm
why did you how did you manage to rent
the rooms are in 10 days when the
letting agent could and what did you do
differently to what most management
companies do
well i was very aggressive with it i put
up an ad immediately as soon as the
rooms were ready i put up an ad
and i kind of gave it a real good
friendly approach in the dialogue i also
made sure that the decor had pops and
versatile colors
and i think psychologically people were
actually attracted
to the property online because of the
colors i also didn't just put up an ad
and sit down and wait for people to get
back to me i also messaged every single
person
looking for yes then to top it all off
i then went onto the street literally
just there
i asked people who were in that hmo over
there said is anyone looking for runs
yeah and they were yeah so it was so
many different ways
but it it's full so this property you
bought this
how would you pay for it two five seven
257
now when you've finished everything in
the basement and you've turned that into
into rooms uh i know the refurb is done
in most of the house but
including absolutely everything once
it's done how much will the refurb be in
total
um i believe once everything is done it
should be
pretty much 38 000. okay so you're
talking about in total about 295
for everything based on what the rents
will be because it's going to be value
based on a commercial valuation how much
are you expecting the valuation to come
in
well i've been speaking to my broker
like every week and he basically said
that the property
should be valued at about 4 30 4 40
if we can get the other three rooms
downstairs which means that you'll have
made
well over a hundred thousand pound
profit which was the plan yeah which is
fantastic
yeah so everything that i put in should
have should be coming back yes which is
great and the equity in the property is
likely to be about a hundred and thirty
thousand pounds
even if it's down value even if it
wasn't still a hundred grand still happy
100 on one deal's not bad we only need
to do that ten times and you've made a
million pounds
now talk a little bit about because you
are getting a little bit closer now to
the goal talking
about everyone doesn't know what we're
doing what we've been working on so
we're doing a millionaire challenge
where we samuel's basically put a
challenge out to me to see if i can
become
a millionaire within a year yeah and and
the financial freedom challenge
obviously we didn't do it in a week but
you became financially free which took a
few years
joined the academy a couple of years
back absolutely
and now working towards being a
millionaire yeah so i'm using all of the
tools
all of the different lessons from the
academy to actually
be able to become a millionaire which
obviously i've executed these option
agreements i bought hmo
and you know developments and things
like that that's awesome so
guys if you want to follow jl's journey
we're going to be doing video updates
very regularly
and at the very end we're going to piece
everything together in an incredible
millionaire challenge documentary so if
you like
the sound of that then subscribe to the
channel which you can do up around here
if you want to see
the last video that we did of this exact
house you can check out that video
over here and don't forget to smash the
like button subscribe
and we'll see you next time